[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud proud and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] him
[Music]
god
guns
babies
that is their platform they say they're
pro-life
they say they're american they say
they're patriotic
they say save the children
but they stand back
and watch children get slaughtered
time after time after time this will not
be the last time that the gqp
has blood on their hands last week it
was a [ __ ] grocery store and a church
yesterday was a school second third
fourth graders teachers
the shooter in yuvali
was not a lone gunman
he had the help
of governor abbott the nra senator ted
cruz john cornyn you weak [ __ ]
oh i'm gonna back out of the nra cause
it looks bad you know what looks bad you
know what looks really [ __ ] bad john
cornyn you weak piece of [ __ ]
dead children's bodies all over the
floor of a school
that's what we should do
we should make the governor and the
senators and all the gqp go mop up those
children off the floor
there's a law you can [ __ ] pass
i think the country is sick and [ __ ]
tired of this [ __ ]
this is america folks
the land of the armed and the home of
the broken
every parent in the in america this
morning
was nervous
about sending their children to a school
think about it for a second
i know you hugged your children when
they came home
i know you held them as long as they
would let you hold them
mental health mental illness we need
mental health yeah we are going to need
a lot of mental health in this [ __ ]
country can you imagine the mental
health care
that the other students the other staff
members the teachers
the police officers the [ __ ] parents
of the dead slaughtered children
you pieces a weak [ __ ]
we're gonna watch a really a really lot
of footage today
of good takes and bad takes
and you're i'm not gonna let you look
away
we have voters in this country
that only only pick out a few [ __ ]
issues and that's what they vote on
and every single time it's to take away
your rights
your right to your uterus your right to
your [ __ ] vote
and your right to your children's safety
you don't think we have the [ __ ]
right to live in this country you don't
think our children have the right to
learn without being scared that they're
gonna be [ __ ] mowed down torn apart
by a semi-automatic rifle because you
got a boner for guns
so you can protect your tv and you can
shoot politicians you dirty
[ __ ]
you dirty [ __ ]
nope i'm not gonna shut up i'm not gonna
stop talking
when we're in a country where a goddamn
gun has more [ __ ] rights than a
woman's uterus it's time it is so it is
[ __ ] time if you're not ready to go
to the [ __ ] polls and vote every
single one of these [ __ ] out
you're doing it wrong this morning
i don't care if you're [ __ ]
republican if you're a goddamn democrat
i don't care if you're a [ __ ]
conservative if you're a parent in this
country a [ __ ] grandparent in this
country you should be ready tomorrow to
vote these [ __ ] out they are
gonna go to the [ __ ] nra conference
in texas and cheer cheer the slaughter
children yesterday
that's what they're gonna do
and we're just gonna stand here and let
them do it
take our democracy away from us make
this into an autocracy
i'm not
i'm gonna keep yelling into this
microphone i'm gonna keep motivating you
to stay [ __ ] pissed
it's time to fight with the ballot
enough is enough of this [ __ ]
when will it [ __ ] end
when can we send our kids to school to
learn
and not be slaughtered
torn apart
by a piece of weaponry that we
manufacture in this country so some
[ __ ] dude or some dumb [ __ ]
conservative somewhere can take a
picture of it in front of a [ __ ]
christmas tree
you dumb [ __ ]
i've had about a [ __ ] enough of this
stupid [ __ ]
where the minority ideology in this
country gets to tell us what the [ __ ] to
do
90 90 9 out of 10 [ __ ] people
realize it's a good idea to do a goddamn
background check before you give someone
a goddamn weapon that is designed to
kill multiple human beings
nine out of ten people already [ __ ]
realize it
joe manchin says oh well i'll do
anything anything i can do to stop
children from being slaughtered in
schools well do something [ __ ]
[ __ ] your career [ __ ] you being a
senator who cares about your [ __ ]
votes
stop giving a [ __ ] about your own
goddamn power
those children had no [ __ ] power not
a god damn out of power to stop that
gunman those [ __ ] cops had no power
to stop that gunman
good guy with a gun give me a [ __ ]
break [ __ ] you
good guy with a gun you son of a [ __ ]
ken paxton you [ __ ] so you want
you want [ __ ] teachers you want
teachers to be police officers
and the police officers can't even stop
these [ __ ] with these weapons
that's the intent
the intent when they [ __ ] manufacture
this stuff is to make sure that you are
not stopped with the gun
what don't you get
how can't we [ __ ] understand this
it's time to vote every one of those
[ __ ] out
we need to be single issue voters
in this country right now
not yesterday not tomorrow not next week
right mother [ __ ] now
one issue voters and the issue is [ __ ]
you gqp
[ __ ] you
that's our issue that's it right there
their republican vote them the [ __ ] out
they want your children slaughtered they
don't give a [ __ ] about you they don't
want your rights taken away from you
they don't give a [ __ ] about you
you dumb [ __ ]
and until they do that is our one issue
[ __ ] you gqp
[ __ ] you
that's your issue go vote go engage give
money
don't give thoughts and prayers
type in five dollars to your local
[ __ ] congressman who can beat that
[ __ ] gqp or who's gonna [ __ ]
have blood on his hands from the nra who
won't [ __ ] stomach
stomach even standing in front of a
goddamn microphone and talking about the
slaughter of children that we can stop
we can stop this
we can stop it you can stop it
go vote them the [ __ ] out if you're not
registered go get registered
right now if your [ __ ] family if your
[ __ ] community members are not
registered now is the time right now not
tomorrow now today
commit
to the one issue of [ __ ] you gqp
that's the issue one only one you're out
of here [ __ ] you have proven
that you have no intent to govern no
intent to put american people in front
of your power
even slaughtered [ __ ] children
mental health get the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ]
you need a [ __ ] head check you sons
of [ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] pissed
and i'll stay pissed
until these [ __ ] are gone
they don't want to create policy
that prevents children from being
slaughtered
well fine
we'll vote them the [ __ ] out
we
we can't even we can't even get these
[ __ ] to agree
what 90 of people in this country
believe
that yes it is really [ __ ] boneheaded
to not do a background check on a piece
of equipment that is designed to kill
human beings
multiple human beings
what are you gonna do
that's my question what are you gonna do
i'm talking to you the audience
what are you going to do
you got many options you can give money
to campaigns
i'll tell you one [ __ ] option if
you're in texas right now i'd be giving
every [ __ ] nickel out of your goddamn
couch every penny out of your couch to
better o'rourke
every [ __ ] nickel
greg abbott is the reason why this
happened
cheering cheering that anyone can get a
gun anywhere anytime
cheering it
tweeting out oh man we really are in a
[ __ ] competition with other states to
have as many guns on the street as we
possibly can have because that's what
makes us safe as you can see yesterday
the evidence is clear
more guns equals dead bodies
and that's what they want
i was in junior high when columbine
happened
i was about to go into high school
when the national news was that high
schools weren't safe
your classmates could come in and
[ __ ] murder you
and i lived in rural america where every
kid had access to guns every
[ __ ] had access to guns there
was guns in every household in rural
america
now they weren't the weapons that we
have today because you gotta remember in
the 1990s there was the assault weapons
ban
but we still wondered when we go to high
school
are we gonna have to dodge [ __ ]
bullets are we gonna have to hide on her
desk are we gonna have to run from our
classmates in the cafeteria to save our
[ __ ] lives
here we are
over 20 years later
and they're still giving us the same old
[ __ ]
good guy bad guy [ __ ]
guns don't kill people people kill
people
same old [ __ ] same old [ __ ] and these
politicians buy it hook line sinker
because the nra comes to them and says
hey look [ __ ]
you don't vote with us we'll vote you
out and we got the voters look at our
register [ __ ]
and they want their power
their power is way more important than
19
19 children being stacked up like
cordwood in texas their power is way
more important than that duh
in the 1990s after columbine happened
the nra
wayne lapierre went to congress
and we're in support of background
checks we're supporting regulation
but they soon found out they soon found
out that mass shootings doesn't equal
bad business
mass shootings equals good business they
can really stoke fear
inside of their small percentage their
small handful of people in this country
that believe this garbage
and make them go by guns because they're
afraid the government's gonna take them
well i'm here to say to all you gun nuts
out there who think you [ __ ] want the
second amendment and have the second
amendment
you better get to the negotiating table
[ __ ] fast
quick fast and in the hurry i don't know
how long this is gonna sustain
especially with me yelling and screaming
i'm not gonna stop i don't give a [ __ ]
i'm not going to stop you won't stop me
try to cancel me try to turn me off not
gonna happen i'm gonna yell and scream
at somebody
i'm not gonna stop are you gonna stop
it's time to [ __ ] take our [ __ ]
country back it's time to vote it's time
to be one issue voters [ __ ] you gqp
[ __ ] you that's your [ __ ] one issue
they want to reign terror down on your
communities they want to strike fear
into the hearts of your children
19 children
went to school yesterday
thinking that they'd ride the bus home
thinking that their parents would pick
them up
thinking they were safe
there's even an armed cop
at the school to keep him safe the good
guy
with the gun
there he is
trained
with a badge licensed
paid for
and because the republicans won't pluck
their heads out of their asses in this
country and realize
it doesn't matter if you have an armed
guard
at the school it doesn't [ __ ] matter
when the person comes with better body
armor
and a more efficient weapon to kill
human beings
it doesn't matter if you have an armed
guard it doesn't matter if teachers have
weapons
they're just targets at that point
what's next can paxton you piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] you're gonna make sure
every child every first grader every
kindergartner every second grader
has a semi-automatic raffle a rifle
slung over their back so they can
protect themselves
when someone with the piece of armory
that you won't regulate comes into a
school
and tears them to pieces rips them the
shreds
with a war machine huh
is that what you want you want the kids
to be armed too i mean that's the next
step ken paxton you [ __ ]
where are you gonna go from here huh
it's time now is the time
it was time a long time ago columbine
sandy hook parkland
[ __ ] last week
had a grocery store in buffalo new york
for crying out [ __ ] loud
america
pluck your head
out of your [ __ ] ass and realize
that your vote matters
your ballot matters your voice matters
it [ __ ]
matters
but only you can make it matter only you
you're the one that goes to the poll
you're the one that talks to your
friends you're the one that says the
things that you need to say to your
community members to motivate them
to make sure these scumbags do not have
their hands on our policy
because their bloody hands are all over
it
and they're not going to stop they're
not going to
we're going to watch we're going to look
at and watch a lot of really [ __ ]
gross takes
on a whole stack of dead children's
bodies this morning
and again maybe that is the solution
maybe we should pass a law to where when
there is a school shooting
and there's dead children that our
politicians who make the policies about
keeping those schools safe have to go
mop up
mop up the carnage
and clean it up themselves maybe maybe
just maybe their power won't be as
important
it's enough of this [ __ ]
america's pissed
parents are pissed
teachers are pissed
this
didn't have to happen
we are doing this to ourselves
we are yes we
you must become one issue voters now
right now
and it's to vote out anyone who has an r
next to their goddamn name
all the way down to the [ __ ]
dog catcher
if they even have a stench a stench just
a whiff
of the nra the republican party trumpism
and maga vote them the [ __ ]
out
it's enough of this craziness
even the ones that are like oh well i'm
not i'm not queuing on crazy but that
inner race stuff wink love that
love that nope out [ __ ]
enough of it
and it's up to us it's up to you i'm
talking to you now it is up to you
not just to go vote but you have to give
money to these campaigns if you can
afford it you have to talk to your
community members you have to organize
you have to organize against these
[ __ ] fascists
you don't think that this is fascism
they love this they love this stuff
ted cruz is practically laughing
practically laughing when he blames
the shooting that happened yesterday on
democrats
as if democrats haven't tried their
damnedest in every [ __ ] way possible
in every legislator in the entire
country to either pass legislation that
would make sure these weapons do not end
up in the hands or even manufactured
and they have either been stopped by
republicans or they can't stop the
legislation that puts these guns on the
street
in texas
as long as you have a heartbeat and
you're [ __ ] breathing you get to have
a murder weapon
you get to have a machine of war so you
can go into an elementary school and mow
down
and murder 19 children
why not it's texas pew pew pew pew
i have a lot more faith in texas net
i believe there's a hell of a lot of
people in texas that do not want that to
be texas
oh but tony people in texas they love
their guns
more than their children
more than their community members more
than the teachers who teach their
children
more than the police officers that have
to [ __ ] protect the school
with gunfire
are you listening
they had to send a swat team to a school
because greg abbott just was in a
competition of how many guns he can sell
in the state of texas
now is the time right
[ __ ]
now
to show them
that they will not do this to our
country and you can do that by being a
one-issue voter
and that issue is [ __ ] you gop [ __ ] you
vote them the [ __ ] out
it's time right now
if you want this to stop
if you want to make sure that a woman's
uterus has more rights than a [ __ ]
firearm in this country if you want to
make sure that your children have the
right to go to school and to be safe
to not be scared that someone's gonna
come in and cut them up with a goddamn
weapon of war
that the police officers don't have to
worry about protecting a goddamn
elementary school
from warlike gunfire it's not a school
zone anymore it's a [ __ ] war zone
and only we can change it
it's up to us they're not going to do it
you think republicans are going to do
this hell to the no
they're not going to do this republicans
are not going to do this they are not
going to change a goddamn thing not a
[ __ ] thing if you think republicans
are going to get off their asses and do
something you just look at joe manchin
who relies on republicans to vote for
him he's like yeah i'll do anything
anything possible anything in the world
that saved children at schools from
being shot by guns what about the
filibuster mr mansion oh well i can't do
that
i mean when i mean anything i mean
nothing
and he's a democrat who relies on
republicans to vote for him
you think the republicans who rely on
republicans to vote for them are going
to do something get the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ] they are not going to do
a god damn thing not a [ __ ] thing
not a [ __ ] thing and i ain't gonna
put up with this though democrats won't
do [ __ ] [ __ ] there's a goddamn bill
right now hr8 sitting sitting there to
be voted on
for background just background checks
just just that that's not even enough to
[ __ ] stop
the gun violence in this country but
only just just that just that [ __ ]
thing that 90 percent of the country
agree on yeah you should probably pass a
background check to get a [ __ ] weapon
that mows down
dozens of human beings you might you
might want to do that
this is what happens when we have the
minority of ideology controlling parts
of our government and that is up to you
and you may say oh well tony my district
is rigged i'm in a jerry who gives a
[ __ ]
stop with the excuses
are you tired of republicans excuses are
you tired of that [ __ ] good don't have
your own
don't have your own excuse now is not
the time to have excuses
they're taking away macbooks they want
to marry your children and they want to
have them slaughtered in schools
yesterday's a sad day in our country and
tomorrow will be too
there'll be another one don't worry
it'll be another sad day
you'll shed tears
they'll send tots and pears
they'll talk about how oh it's a tragedy
and mental illness and
constitutional rights and blah blah blah
blah blah
tomorrow will be another sad day
because they won't they're not going to
do a thing
they're not going to do a [ __ ] thing
but you can
you sure as hell can
you have the power
so if you find these races
where you have one of these nra gun nuts
in the race
gift to their opponent
campaign for their opponent
put a bumper sticker on signed in yard
he'll buy a goddamn flag
wave it from your [ __ ] pickup truck
whatever it takes folks
whatever it takes
to make sure our children are safe
how is this how is this
such a hard idea
anything
anything to keep our [ __ ] children
safe
it just is real rich
that we have to take a lecture from the
people who say save the children
and we can't even
we can't even get these [ __ ] idiots
to stop them
from slaughtering our children
we'll be right back right after this
break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy by the time we reached dc
we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim
skull
near run out of natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again
yours
bob
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the lid
loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
ears
tammy
[ __ ] a [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking to the break
thanks for hanging around
[Music]
for my cathartic release there
as you know i'm very pissed off i know
my co-host here gabe sanchez who's been
waiting in the wing waiting for me to
stop viewing here
um
gabe there's a lot of footage out there
there's a lot of bad takes there's some
good takes we're going to watch some
good takes yeah
but i want to get your take on this
because i know you have some thoughts um
i i have a daughter who's
a second grader so it's it hit it hit
really close
i finally got to have her sit on my lap
last night and i was hoping that she
hadn't heard the news and i was hoping
that i wouldn't actually have to say
anything to her about what happened in
uvalde texas yesterday and she did not
um and i did not bring it up because
i don't want her to be scared
to to go to a school so
but i know you have your own thoughts
because uh there were some people out
there
hurdling some um things about this this
shooter and i'm not gonna say his name
we don't really have to say his name but
um they've already had accusations um
out there and it it just the the the the
bad takes and the grow stakes they're
they're not going to stop either i mean
they're you know the false flag [ __ ] and
all this happens but
give us your thoughts on
what happened yesterday because we were
live on the air when uh we got yeah
we're in the last uh
last 10 minutes of the show
yeah the initial reports is that there
wasn't they didn't know if anyone was
injured and then i think there was
another part of one injured which must
have been the grandmother um and then
they there was the report that they had
uh they had subdued the shooter or
whatever um that's the only reports that
we really had at that moment
yeah we really it was only hours later
that we found out that there was um
dead children stacked up like cordwood
and i'm gonna say it very vulgary i
don't give a [ __ ] if you if you if you
think i'm gonna lightfoot around what
actually happened where they're mopping
up floors today they're mopping up
children's [ __ ] body parts off the
floor down in texas well then you got it
wrong because that's how we're gonna
that's how i'm gonna say it
because we need to we need to stop
numbing ourselves of this this is
ridiculous last week it was it was the
patrons at a [ __ ] grocery store that
we had to mop up patrons at a [ __ ] uh
uh
the church in california and now this
week
children children that we have to mop up
off the floor in texas it's [ __ ]
ridiculous i mean we couldn't even go
two weeks you know we went 10 days
between
the buffalo mass shooting
and this mass shooting
i mean there's been a mass shooting
every single day it's becoming every day
occurrence in this country the fact that
we live in a country where that's just
commonplace
is
is disgusting it is vile it is so
twisted
and [ __ ] up
i mean
there's an undeniable correlation
between the number of guns in america
and the number of gun related deaths in
america like that is you cannot dispute
that that is fact
the numbers despite the fact that people
on the gqp want to ban math
you don't even have to go to ronda
santa's school of banned mathematics you
know how absolutely [ __ ] up this is
it's it's 1.88 mass shootings per day
we've had
252 mass shootings
in the last
134 days and i'm sure we're gonna have
another one today and i'm sure we're
gonna have another one tomorrow and the
next day and the next day and the next
day
i mean i don't know when it's gonna be
enough
400 mass shootings per year 700 800 a
thousand like at what point
does the gqp say okay you know what
enough innocent children have died
at what point
are they gonna stop and say oh [ __ ]
we're part of the problem
we are absolutely 100 part of the
problem
when are we going to say oh yeah you
know what we should actually fix this
and the thing is the bottom line at the
end of the day the only way that we're
gonna actually make change
is just like you said
is to go and vote
if we don't vote these people out
they're gonna continue to send their
empty thoughts and their empty prayers
and they go speak at nra conventions
just days after a mass shooting
days after a mass shooting where they
killed innocent children
children that won't go home
that won't be able to be tucked in
that won't be able to wake up and have
breakfast with our family
and then of course you've got these
families that are grieving the community
is grieving
and then you've got people like marjorie
taylor green trying to throw out some bs
thing like it's mental health
well if it's mental health then do
something about it
[ __ ] do something about it
like at what point does the gqp need to
stop and look and be like okay yeah
there's a real problem this is an
epidemic
we need to do something about it
but no no no no people like marjory
taylor green are gonna tell you you know
what we actually don't need gun control
we don't need gun reform you know what
we need
more god god's gonna solve the problem
because thoughts and prayers have
already done so much for this country
the gqp has [ __ ] the bed again
and again
and again
they failed us
they failed our children
i mean just like you mentioned earlier
you got ken paxton saying oh you know
what the actual thing because i predict
this to continue happening
is to give teachers with guns
so what you want to defund schools and
take away school supplies but instead
you want to give them a glock you want
to say hey yeah take this smith and
what's a 9 millimeter along with your
erasers and your and your chalk
welcome to the first day of school
they couldn't even finish the [ __ ]
school year they had two days left
before they were able to go out and run
and be free and have fun this summer
and now 19 children 19 babies are dead
it's disgusting man like again it's
gonna happen
tomorrow it's there's probably gonna be
another mass shooting today honestly
i mean just running the numbers
it's gonna happen today
it's gonna happen tomorrow
it ain't gonna stop i mean that's
that's the whole design behind this
system right i mean like i said in the
1990s um when columbine in the late 90s
when the columbine happened
um you know
the nra was like whoa whoa this is going
to be bad for business and then they
quickly discovered that mass shootings
were not bad for business mass shootings
were good for the gun manufacturers
especially especially after the george w
bush and republicans let the assault
weapons ban expire folks we have done
this before in this country
we've had this before for 10 years from
1992 to 2002 we had an assault weapons
ban
it worked
we did not have the mass shootings that
we have today
and we did not have politicians standing
in front of christmas trees
i mean the thing that pisses me off the
most is when people in a gqp decide to
use mental health as the scapegoat yeah
i mean they want to they want to say
it's a mental health issue we've got a
mental health problem in this country
okay fine if that really is how you feel
then let's do something about it but if
i recall
it was under your president trump your
cult leader your fascist [ __ ] orange
wannabe mussolini
that banned
revoked an obama-era gun check for
people with mental illness
well did the admit that all this thing
is all distraction it's all distraction
it's it's to make you talk about an
issue that isn't guns
right that's what it is that's the whole
that's the good guy bad guy [ __ ]
i mean
just the fallacy of good guy bad guys
the the fact and
and when you hear people like ken paxton
try to say
oh the only way to actually solve this
problem and prevent future mass
shootings is to give a teacher a gun so
they can keep it in their side little
drawer here
so when they're pulling out their
highlighters and their pens they
remember they got a glock right there
ready to go because having guns in every
classroom all that'll keep everyone safe
from gunfire i'm sure i'm sure that'll
keep everyone safe from gunfire because
that's that's how you prevent gabe
that's how you prevent gunfire is more
gunfire like i mean a bullet stops
another bullet like
mid
mid point like it's [ __ ] neo in the
matrix like it stops at midpoint they
collide boom it nullifies it it doesn't
even matter anymore the other thing that
stops that stops mass shooters is having
an armed guard you know they said that
you know after after uh
sandy hook and parkland let's just put
an arm guard there's already armed
guards at every [ __ ] school there's
resource officers there's a guest
goddamn gun
yeah you've got a security guard at a
grocery store yeah
and i said the first one was dead who's
the first one that's dead who's got a
gun
because here's the thing
yeah you can put these people in place
but holy [ __ ] the expectation that this
person is gonna go into work they're not
a cop they're not a a a trained
professional they're not [ __ ] seal
team six
but the assumption
that when they go into work
they're gonna have to use their firearm
that [ __ ] is already traumatic enough
for the people who are trained as cops
but you but you want to assume
that the person that's a security guard
just like a you know a person that works
on an hourly wage probably through a
third party service is gonna have to use
their weapon
they did not wake up that day saying i'm
gonna have to [ __ ] go guns blazing
because somebody's gonna come in and
start shooting people
in no way in no [ __ ] reality
is that
an actual excusable justifiable reason
to give someone the fact that we live in
a country where we've just already
assumed that some random civilian with a
gun is going to go save and risk their
lives
to
to save someone else
is so [ __ ] up and twisted
like you're we force these kids into
this world
and then we say hey but when you're an
adult or any point before that or maybe
after i don't know what's going on
what's gonna happen but there's probably
gonna be more shootings so when you're
born you gotta you got a nine millimeter
in your hand or an ar-15 ready to go you
[ __ ] the baby formula [ __ ] the baby
let's give him glock the real crisis is
not giving babies more guns tony
that's the real crisis right that's what
i mean if that's the gqp if that's the
logic they want to use hey you know what
screw them that we don't actually need
to to help them get developed over time
as they're growing up we need to have
guns in their hands
you got a little rattling toy you got a
little little
blocks and squares and triangles
yeah i want an ar-15 well yeah
like a miniature one you know that that
like that i mean like that would be true
give them something that way they can
take right that way they can take nice
christmas photos in front of the tree
with the with the baby and the
baby-sized gun you know you know you
know the other thing that that is
missing here with ken paxton
i
i don't think a lot of people
um who
are understanding this think about this
for a second because i have some
teachers that are friends and i've asked
them these questions
and here's a question that i ask them
because this this this this 18 year old
he he at one time went to this
elementary school
he knew this school he knew this
building because he went there he's a
community member
he's he's a child himself he's just
turned 18.
and when he turned 18 because he's in
texas he can buy any [ __ ] weapons he
wants but listen if you give teachers
guns here's what you're asking them
think about this for a second folks it's
not some [ __ ] stranger walking into
the school
that's gonna
that this teacher's gonna have to
execute on site that they're wearing
full body armor
this is someone they [ __ ] know this
is a child
this is their student
can you imagine can you imagine for a
second you're in the classroom and
you're teaching your kids everyone's
having a great time maybe some some peop
some children are acting like fools as
children do
it's getting near the end of the day you
got two days
left in the school year
and you hear gunfire down the hallway
and ken paxton has his way and there's a
glock
in the desk
so you grab the firearm because you're
gonna go you're gonna go shoot whoever
shooting up the school
and you run out into the hallway with
the weapon
and there in front of you
is a child
that you recognize
a child that you taught to read
a child that you taught math to
a child that you had parent teacher
conference with
sat with their family
you know their family you know their
friends
you know
the ins and outs of that child
because you taught them
you were their teacher
and here you are because ken paxton
thinks that more guns is a solution
you're faced with the reality that you
have to shoot
this child that you taught to read that
you taught math to
you know their family
you know their middle [ __ ] name
and you're expected
to stop
this person and kill this person
before they kill you before they kill
more children
think about that for a second just think
about think about the [ __ ] psychology
when you're standing in the hallway with
the weapon pointed at a child you know
you would have them sit on the floor in
the carpet to read them stories
now you have to kill them
now you have to kill them because ken
paxton says that's the easiest way
that's to that's the path of least
resistance is to make sure that teachers
have to kill their students and former
students that is the path of least
resistance
think about that for a second think
about the scenario that we're talking
about here
you expect a teacher who is underpaid
and overworked half of them have to buy
their own goddamn [ __ ] school
supplies that's used in their room
and you think this person is the best
line of defense to stand there and shoot
someone they think they love
that's your solution ken paxton
that's the gqp's answer to all your
prayers and thoughts folks
well ken paxton
you can take that idea and you can stick
it straight up your [ __ ] ass
with your thoughts and your prayers and
your dumb [ __ ] solutions
because giving teachers guns to shoot
students is not a solution
it's not
ken paxton who's i can't even believe we
have to even say this he's the attorney
general who is under federal indictment
who won his primary
and you're wondering what the single
issue is to vote in this country
the single issue is to tell the gqp to
[ __ ] off that is the single issue that's
your single issue you can be a one-issue
voter that's it
when someone asks you why you're voting
for who you're voting for you say
because i i'm voting against the
republicans i'm voting against them
taking my rights away i'm voting against
them banning math i'm voting them
against wanting to stack up dead
children like cordwood
in schools because they won't because
the nra
just gives them power
that's your one issue that's it that's
it you don't need anything else
and really honestly i don't care if
you're a conservative or liberal or
moderate or an independent i don't give
a [ __ ]
we're well beyond ideology at this point
we're well beyond it we are we are just
in a situation where there's one party
who wants to control power with the
minority ideology in this country and
they want to continue to continue
continue
to take away your [ __ ] democracy away
from you because part of your democracy
is to a real well-regulated militia well
regulated
that's your constitutional [ __ ] power
to your democracy
you have the right
to life and liberty
you think you think those parents
and you led that have to [ __ ] go
identify their children's slaughtered
bodies
because i'm sure i'm sure it's just a
beautiful sight when a when a child's
body is ripped apart by a semi-automatic
rifle
and i'm gonna be graphic i'm gonna
continue to be you cannot be numb by
this
i'm sure that's just a beautiful sight
that a parent wants to see and i'm sure
the one word that comes to their mind
well thank god we have our liberty and
we can buy semi-automatic rivals well
thank god
thank god we got that god-given right
i mean that's that's all they would
probably be thinking as they're trying
to identify
the body
of their second grader i'm sure of it
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
i mean can you imagine being a teacher
going through school doing teach for
america and saying okay you know i've
got all these things i got these debts
to pay off and but you know what i truly
love what i do
i want to be
the person that fosters a community and
helps these children grow and develop
especially
in states that have rules and laws that
are ass [ __ ] backwards because i
as a teacher feel maybe i can make a
difference
maybe i can be the one who actually sets
them on a different path so they're not
going to be a bigot or racist or a
gun-toting maga member
and then they show up to school
and they said okay there's a new policy
we cut funding
for construction paper and art supplies
and other things that actually
creates this environment for these
children right we banned the books we
defunded this
but we reallocated funding
and we put it toward our defense
and they're like oh okay well what does
that mean exactly
i said well
what we decided to do
was give everyone a round of ammunition
and a handheld gun
and you're going to put it in your in
your desk so if anything were to happen
you're ready to go
but we're not going to train you and you
don't have to have a license because
then you know this is texas
and we don't have to do a background
check and we don't have to make sure
that you're okay and
that you don't already have some
existing trauma
so you know what
go for it
that's what they want
at the beginning the school year they
give them a checklist of things they've
taken away
and a long list of guns that they've
allowed in the school
because that's really what it is they're
swapping one for the other assuming that
guns are going to be the proper thing
for education
the type of learning environment that
you want your child in if you want to
train a kid with a gun as [ __ ] up as
that may be go do it in your house
do it in the in the privacy of your own
home
again
i've seen videos
of i saw a video yesterday of a little
girl that i've seen previously who was
just shooting off rounds
if that's what you want to teach in your
own home so be it right obviously you
know government can't tell you what to
do so you do your own thing as [ __ ] up
as that may be to teach a child that
young how to [ __ ]
run off around
on a handheld gun or an ar-15 that is
the equivalent height as they are
whatever it's [ __ ] up
but to bring that into a school
and say
this is how we're going to stop this in
the future
this is the only
[ __ ]
solution
that we have to offer because we're not
willing to give up those nra donations
we're not willing to to get those
lobbyists those nra lobbyists and
pro-gun lobbyists out of out of the
senate in congress
no no we want more money we want more
money
so instead
we're not going to take that
and this school has now officially been
renamed
to the smith and wesson elementary
school
that's the type of reality they want to
live in
it's absolutely ridiculous
and we got to go to the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends here gabe because
we gotta surf we gotta show everyone we
gotta give light to this we can't look
away there's a few videos that are gonna
be hard to watch
um
and there's some really bad takes but
there's some really good takes
so let's do this let's start the
countdown
and let's go to the tweety tweets and
trendy trends and let's see what's
happening on this topic
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the
county michael's podcast this is the
point where we go through the tweety
tweets and trinity trends
and boy has it been a hell
of a 20 hours or so
um since we got news um last night the
golden state warriors and the dallas
mavericks were playing in texas
it was a big game apparently i think
it's conference finals is what it is um
so it was a big game
and uh
the coach of the golden state warrior
steve kerr who i i know steve kirk
because i was a chicago bulls fan gabe i
think you were a chicago bulls fan
steve kerr steve kerr was a chicago bull
for a while he has many rings with the
chicago bulls
um
warning been doing a great job with the
warriors too right absolutely but the
one thing that i'll say about steve kerr
no matter what team he plays for no
matter what team he coaches
is if anyone knows anything about steve
kerr his dad was killed by gun violence
um and he did not get to say goodbye to
his father uh
he did not get the you know his dad was
dead that that he got the phone call and
his dad was dead from gunfire um so he
has he has he has experience in this
area
and last night when he came to the
microphone and there's a lot of
different versions of this but i
actually tweeted out the golden state
warriors version because it was dead
center on steve
um and steve spoke
um
from his heart
some would say eloquently someone would
say with passion some would say with
anger someone say with frustration
someone say with truth
but more than anything he spoke with
experience
and he laid the basketball aside for a
second and basically told the reporters
i'm not gonna talk about basketball i'm
gonna talk about what's important and
we're gonna play basketball later and
you're gonna get the report on that
you're gonna do all that [ __ ]
we're gonna talk about something that's
more important so let's play the
of clip steve kerr human being steve
kerr here more than coach i think
american steve kerr
someone who has experienced
gun violence taking someone he loves
let's listen in
oh i'm not going to talk about
basketball nothing's uh happened with
our team in the last six hours
we're going to start the same way
tonight
any basketball questions don't matter
since we left shoot on 14 children were
killed 400 miles from here
and a teacher
and in the last 10 days we've had
elderly black people killed in a
supermarket
in buffalo we've had asian church-goers
killed
in southern california and now we have
children murdered at school
when are we going to do something
i'm tired i'm i'm so tired of getting up
here and
offering condolences to
to the
devastated families that are out there
i'm so tired of the excuse i'm sorry i'm
tired of the moments of silence
enough
there's 50 senators
right now who refuse to vote on h.r 8
which is a background check rule that
the house passed a couple years ago it's
been sitting there for two years
and there's a reason they won't vote on
it to hold on to power
so i ask you mitch mcconnell i ask all
of you senators who refuse to do
anything about the violence in school
shootings and supermarket shootings i
ask you
are you going to put your own
desire for power ahead of the lives
of our children and our elderly and our
church-goers
because that's what it looks like
it's what we do every week
so
i'm fed up i've had enough
we're going to play the game tonight
but i want every person here every
person listening to this to think about
your own child or grandchild or mother
or father or sister brother how would
you feel if this happened to you today
we can't get numb to this we can't sit
here and just read about it and go well
let's have a moment of silence yeah go
dubs you know
come on mavs let's go
that's what we're gonna do we're gonna
go play a basketball game
and 50 senators in washington are going
to hold us hostage
do you realize that 90 percent of
americans
regardless of political party want
background check universal background 90
of us we are being held hostage by 50
senators
in washington who refuse to even put it
to a vote despite
what we the american people want
they won't vote on it because they want
to hold on to their own power
it's pathetic i've had enough
coach american
human being steve kerr
there um
gabe
steve kerr spoke out about this issues
for many years he's he's
spoke on many issues in the past other
than just basketball
but um
it seems like coach steve kerr has had
enough here
and i think anyone who has a platform
and i just want to say and hey you know
who's steve kerr to listen to me tony
michaels but
um if he would if you were to see this
steve thank you very much um for using
your platform because there was millions
of people watching um that video that
the golden state warriors because they
didn't have to clip that out and post it
either right um you know and promote his
message there that is not basketball
that is actually he's saying [ __ ]
basketball [ __ ] basketball
right and the basketball organization
that he worked with amplified his
message and that video currently has
over 26 million views
i mean i'd argue that you know in many
ways you wouldn't have basketball
if this problem continues to happen you
know do you talk about killing innocent
lives innocent children who might grow
up one day to be some nba star
like there is a direct connection
between
these lives that the gqp so desperately
want to protect and save yeah save the
children right
yeah save the children you'd think that
a pro-life party would actually have a
plan in place
to stop this epidemic but no it's
whatever you know it is what it is and
that's how life goes anyway you gotta
have this baby now right
i guess what it is well i mean the
uterus does have more [ __ ] rights in
this country
or it has less rights than a [ __ ] gun
that's where we're at
and the jets what the gqp wants now
there's some other good takes
but there is this video here and i want
everyone to watch it
it's heartbreaking it's crushing
but this is america folks i mean it
shouldn't be but this video here is
america
american is apple pie americans is hot
dogs and hamburgers in the 4th of july
christmas trees and ar-15s
this is america that we're about to
watch
land
of the armed and home of the broken
do not look away
this is the anguish
these parents are standing here waiting
to know if their child is cut up in
pieces by a firearm
because republicans just don't have the
[ __ ] courage to tell the nra to [ __ ]
off here it is watch because i'm going
to play it a couple times do not look
away do not mute this
watch it
is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
right here
[Music]
is
it's time to pass some legislation that
makes anyone who receives money from the
nra
anyone who um tries to stop gun gun
safety
um reform anyone who stands in the way
of
innocent children being slaughtered that
when these people when these innocent
americans
and these innocent people are
slaughtered
in our schools churches grocery stores
community halls streets
basketball stadiums because that's next
we should make them
the ones who vote against it the ones
who have to hang on to their power like
mitch mcconnell
and joe manchin
those [ __ ]
those are the ones who we we should pay
government money
we should pay for the mops the buckets
the plane tickets to fly them to every
single one of these scenes of crime
and make them mop up these bodies make
them stack the dead little children up
like cord wood
maybe maybe then maybe then they'll
understand what the [ __ ] people are
yelling and screaming about maybe maybe
that'll change your mind mitch
maybe i'll change your mind 50 senators
that steve kerr was talking about
because folks
this is not a two-sided [ __ ] issue
this that is all [ __ ] nonsense
that is all nonsense
there is one weapon that these
[ __ ] are using against us and
it is the
2a second amendment gun nuts who go vote
that's what they're using to keep power
listen to me when i tell you the power
of the nra is not their money it is that
they get people to go
vote
that's the power and you have that power
you can have one issue one only one and
that's to stop
the republican party
to stop them from their [ __ ]
that is your power to stop what we just
saw because what you just saw is
becoming more and more american
you know we we always get these montages
of the the flag waving and
people having a great celebration at the
4th of july and having thanksgiving
dinner
eating apple pie
grilling hot dogs hamburgers and steaks
you know all the great american things
but what's more american than what we
just watched
where parents are and family members are
agonizing in anguish
to know if their loved ones the teachers
the staff members the [ __ ] children
were cut up into pieces
by a firearm that republicans just have
to make sure that everyone can own and
anyone can own it really i mean as long
as you got a [ __ ] heartbeat and a
breath you can get one of these
[ __ ] why not it makes us safer
there's proof out there
and that's what they want they want if
there are more
more people in the streets with guns
they'll be able to to protect each other
that's that is the logic that they have
more guns in the streets the safer we
are that is absolutely one hundred
percent
[ __ ]
i like fed up vikings take here thank
god women didn't storm the school and
have an abortion that would be a real
tragedy
because that's the truth you have you
have way more of a right in this country
and in texas
to get a [ __ ] weapon and go into a
school and murder children than you do
for women to choose to save their life
with a with a
a medical procedure because that's their
choice
the sad reality is like you're talking
about this is the you know this is the
image of america like
this is the american dream and well it
is the american nightmare really
like that is the world we live in you
you hope you're like i'm going to
america and i'm going to have the land
of opportunity and i'm going to build
myself up and pull myself up on my
bootstraps and do this like well as long
as you've got a gun to protect yourself
you can
because if you don't
someone's gonna come in guns blazing and
even if you had a gun
you're not okay you're not safe
you're not protected
and even if you are the victim of a gun
shooting
the government says well you can go [ __ ]
yourself
because
we've got people our lawmakers who are
paid by the nra
to stop it just like steve kerr said
they're wielding all the power and
despite the fact that 90 percent of
americans support background checks
despite
where they are on the political side of
the aisle
the people who are actually creating the
laws are holding us hostage
we're the people in the goddamn bank
while they're robbing it
we're crying we don't know if we're
gonna make it out alive
but these lawmakers are [ __ ] pulling
cash and it's a [ __ ] cash grab and
they've got guns pointed to our head
well here here you have governor mike
parson he's the he's the great governor
in the great state of missouri this
piece of [ __ ]
he's a he he's a former sheriff gabe
this guy was in law enforcement okay
he says he says first lady teresa and i
are deeply saddened to hear the tragedy
out of uh you've already texted [ __ ]
you're not you're not deeply saddened
you're not surprised this is the this is
the [ __ ] this is the idea governor
parsons he says we are praying of course
they're praying of course they're doing
the [ __ ] do-nothing [ __ ] to pray
for the victims families and friends
that they may find strength and peace oh
great in such a difficult oh yeah that's
great that they find that you know
peace and strength
after they they they throw their child's
dead body into a six foot hole and put a
stone on top yeah that's great that's
great mike parsons this is the same
[ __ ] that signed a bill in
missouri that doesn't allow local law
enforcement again this guy is a former
sheriff that doesn't allow local law
enforcement to cooperate
with the federal government on any gun
any gun investigations it is illegal
they can be sued lindsay points it out
here lindsay says reminder that if a
school shooting happened in missouri our
law enforcement officials are prohibited
by law by missouri law from working with
the fbi atf to solve a crime
missouri is a domestic terror safe haven
so here's the thing and lindsay has
didn't point this out like i'm going to
if yesterday
that person with that [ __ ] war
machine went in and [ __ ] mowed down
and tore apart 19 children in missouri
they wouldn't be able to use the the
resources at the fbi or the atf to tell
where that game gun came from when it
was purchased if there was a background
check they wouldn't be able to do any of
that because it is illegal in missouri
to investigate a gun crime and do you
know why gabe you know why it's illegal
what will happen is the family of that
person can sue the law enforcement
agency for [ __ ] for for doing that
investigation in that just in that just
clean so not only not only do you have
guns in in the state of missouri
not only is it a safe haven for guns but
just rest assured that if they
investigate you for murders that you
commit with these war weapons
there is hell to pay
what
i just need to understand what is it
with republican lawmakers that they want
to make the people who are the predators
the people who are attacking others
the the recipients
who should be able to sue
anyone else you've got people who say
hey look look look if you want to shoot
some people yeah [ __ ] it go for it
and if anyone wants to come in that is
not on the state level and wants to say
hey
we're coming after this person
the family
the family
of the attacker
of the perpetrator
gets to go nah i'm suing you guys right
the same way
that when the person the man who rapes
the woman
his family
can sue
the victim yep
yeah why why why wouldn't you want to do
that why why shouldn't the perpetrator
have have rights over the victim gabe
why shouldn't they why shouldn't they
why shouldn't they this is really
[ __ ] dumb i know it defies logic here
but this is why we have to stop them
listen in missouri there is there is
likely
a senate candidate
who was a former governor who is
disgraced he had to resign because
he [ __ ] duct taped his hairdresser to
a treadmill and made her take naked
photos to blackmail her this guy has all
kinds of commercials like he's pew pew
pew pew the same guy
who was on a video with donald trump jr
saying liberals be scared because i've
got a gun right basically threatening to
do what that guy did yesterday
and you have all the taxes to those
children to liberals to someone who has
a certain ideology yeah youth god forbid
you care for another person and want to
give them benefits and health and
education and take care of them right
like a good christian
if you [ __ ] do that though i'm coming
after you right that's the type of
[ __ ] this is right that's the type
of reality that these republicans live
in or you know what
if you want to come after me i'm going
to take from you i'm taking what's yours
even after i've already taken what you
had and you have nothing left to give
i'm gonna take even more
that's what republicans want
rachel bittikoffer here says one of our
favorite political strategists here at
the tony michael spock yes and she's
right she said if you want to help me
out every time you see a post bitching
about congress not doing anything about
guns congress
hop in there with republicans in
congress
because folks that's the thing this this
[ __ ] double-sided [ __ ] that the
media does where oh well there was there
was one democrat
there was one democrat so democrats are
to blame get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ]
stop your nonsense stop your nonsense
there is only one party in this country
that is for pro-democracy and what i
mean by that is for the majority of
ideology to set policy
which if we were to have that
it is very likely that the shooting of
the maga king mass shooter in buffalo
would not have happened last week
the shooting at the at the church at
california would have not happened and
there would be 19 children that would
not know the difference today and 19
sets of parents that would not know the
difference today and they would still be
taking their kids to a safe school and
feeling safe
and it has nothing to do with the
democrats
they're the ones passing bills they're
the ones trying to stop these bills in
these state houses they're doing
everything they can but you keep voting
for republicans
or not voting at all
so go
[ __ ] vote these sons of [ __ ] out
and every time you hear this garbage
about this double-sided [ __ ] that
congress isn't doing anything it's
republicans in congress not doing
anything not a goddamn thing nothing but
[ __ ] fascist obstruction all of it
full stop
get on message it's time to [ __ ] take
our country back from these
[ __ ] and again to to hop on you
know rachel's point here
i want to remind everyone
that again
there was an obama era
rule in place
about putting
people who have mental illness
on the registry and having a background
check
and then trump slowly rolling those back
in a quiet fashion so no one made it
he's a democrat or a republican
is he a democrat or republican trump
yeah oh yeah he's a republican did he
did he take the endorsement from the nra
did he did he say [ __ ] you oh no he took
it did he go to nra conventions and
speak at nra conventions did he do that
he's about to go get another one yeah
anyone who trump endorses anyone any
[ __ ] that utters the words i
love president trump out their [ __ ]
mouse vote them out i don't care what
they tell you what they tell you it is
enough is enough is enough of this manga
trumpism [ __ ] [ __ ] enough of it
and you can do something about it you
one issue voter stop this nonsense i
mean the the messed up thing here is
that
when this
when this rollback happened the nra came
out and said we welcome the president's
call to address the root cause of the
horrific acts of violence that occurred
in our country
but
when obama put the rule in place they
said oh no no no this infringes on the
second amendment right to buy guns
even though the regulation specifically
targeted people who were diagnosed with
mental illness this wasn't a i'm coming
into your home and i'm grabbing your
guns and i'm taking them and i'm i'm not
going to give them back this was
specific for a specific group
not an overarching rule that said we're
going to take your guns and and melt
them down
the nra says one thing and of course
just like the republicans they flip-flop
and say the other thing as a hypocrite
that they are
you know you pointed out you know in the
beginning of the show
after columbine they came up and they're
like listen we'll do what we need to do
yeah we we we want to support background
checks oh wait actually sorry we just
found out that mass shootings
equals more gun sales so
never mind we're going to back out of
that one you guys have a good day and
we're going to keep playing this fanfare
of we will do whatever we can to find
out what the root causes i have no idea
it's like if anyone has seen
i think you should leave with tim
robinson there's a sketch show on
netflix and he he's a hot dog he's in a
hot dog costume as a mascot and he
drives a wienermobile into it into a
retail store and everyone's like oh my
god holy [ __ ] like what happened isn't
it okay meanwhile he's there in a big
hot dog and he's like i don't know
what's going on why do we keep bringing
attention to why this happened it's the
same situation
they're the cause yet yelling
like an arson to a fire oh guys we got
what's going on i don't know who started
this fire this is the fire department
where's the fire department who did this
why would some democrats are regulating
water what the [ __ ] they're regulating
water
speaking of [ __ ] crazy people
here is um infowars alex jones again do
not look away
listen you want to know the percentage
of voters who who where they're getting
their information from here's one
[ __ ] spot
here's the spot that is your competition
for the vote
you wanna you wanna compete for the vote
and for ballots here's who they're
listening to and this is the information
that they're basing their vote on listen
don't look away
eight seven seven seven eight nine two
five three nine eight seven seven seven
eight nine alex
and we're going to get you on air coming
up
owen
look i don't want to say this with stage
provocateur
but we have specifically said with two
years of our leaning mass shootings
that with all the pre-programming that
mass shootings are coming and terrorists
are going to attack and we got to take
the guns and then i'm like well i would
predict a lot of mass shootings
right before the election and then like
clockwork is happening
you know to me it's just very
opportunistic what's happening
there's alex jones hinting at the false
flag [ __ ] they're gonna do it
they're gonna do it because of this
person's name and i'm not gonna say his
name
because he doesn't deserve the fanfare
here on our show
but they're gonna use the name they've
already said it ah he's a trans person
he's the illegal alien and all these
lies about him when last week we tried
to tell the truth
about a white supremacist going into a
grocery store and killing back black
people and they gaslight is like oh
that's not the truth and this week
they're going to tell lies about the
shooter down in texas because it
benefits their power
they don't give a [ __ ] about the truth
they don't care about the truth
we have to make sure that the people who
don't care about the truth don't have
power over our policy
and the things that we in this country
want done with our [ __ ] tax dollars
it's our policy it's our government
we control it do something
i'm not talking to the politicians
because the ones the group of
politicians that we got and if you if
you listen to greg abbott and and and
ken paxton and ted cruz
[ __ ] paul gozar this morning that
piece of [ __ ] marjorie taylor green
mitch mcconnell if you think that group
of [ __ ] is going to do anything
about this you are wrong you are dead
wrong they're going to go to nra and
they're going to cheer the funniest part
about the nra convention that they're
about to go to they're banned from
bringing [ __ ] firearms into there
because it's dangerous
listen to me has that always been the
rule you goddamn right why what gabe why
would they want to risk getting shot by
a firearm yeah i know right that makes
no sense at all and the only way to make
sure that and prevent for themselves
being shot and killed by a firearm is to
make sure that firearms are not allowed
in that building
put a sign out front that says firearms
not allowed
make guards check people make sure
they're not having guns in that building
because gabe in that building
it's unsafe to have guns now outside
that building everywhere else you got
all kinds of good guys with guns that'll
protect you from the bad guys with guns
yeah and the middle of the mental health
problem that is outside that building is
the thing that causes all that gun
violence outside that building but
inside that building there can be no
guns because that would risk that a
bullet might fly somewhere yeah
the did you know that the average
american owns
five guns
i would that does not surprise me
five firearms
we have
300 and well probably at this point over
393 million guns that are in the hands
of civilians
we only have 331 million civilians
in this country
and then you have a large percentage of
those people who are owning multiple
firearms 22 percent of gun owners own
one firearm
and again you've got an average american
owning five
like what what more do you need you know
the people that want to say on the
republican side the gqp oh guys you got
you need to stop indoctrinating our
children yeah right groomers the same
people
that are [ __ ]
caressing guns like they've got some
fetish
where does lauren bobert take [ __ ]
christmas card pictures
yeah where does lauren bob keep her guns
you know where she keeps them
she told us she keeps them in her
bedroom mm-hmm yep
yeah well i mean i i called my i called
my mom last night and i told her i said
i don't know about i don't know about my
younger brother but i don't want those
[ __ ] guns that are in my dad's
cabinet you just go turn those some
[ __ ] in and have them melted down i
don't have any [ __ ] news for those
some [ __ ] not a goddamn one of them
and some of them are family heirlooms
but they're not heirlooms to me i don't
give a [ __ ] you can just go [ __ ] have
those things i don't want them i don't
want them in my house i don't want them
near my children i don't want them near
anybody
it's just not worth it anymore it's not
worth it and if this morning you woke up
as an american
and your thoughts weren't directly to
man
i own these three ar-15s and boy they're
really cool and
i'm i kind of am for gun control and
background checks but am i am i
contributing to the problem by owning
these guns right am i contributing you
you got to think hard about that you got
to think really hard about that thinking
about uh trying to think hard here's
some [ __ ] bonehead this [ __ ] idiot
ken paxton down in in texas he is under
federal indictment
he's been under federal indictment for
the last six or seven years yeah he's a
[ __ ]
i am
dumbfounded right and how nothing has
come of this
and then the guy [ __ ] just won his
nomination for re-election
right well what listen to in this this
[ __ ] clip i believe he because this
is the one you posted this is the one
where he talked about criminals and [ __ ]
right there
he is a [ __ ] criminal
there are a couple clips where he tries
to defend oh they're the murdering type
of crowd right right well yeah not the
not the white collar business stealing
money type criminal like he is yeah you
know what the [ __ ] he needs to own a gun
yeah these poor people right and their
guns right they're the murdering type
right but us white collar folk right
we're defenders of the constitution
people right
right well let's listen to this [ __ ]
bonehead help them second no we need to
continue to try to focus on preventing
this we we can't stop bad people from
doing bad things they're going to
violate murder laws they're not going to
follow guns then why do we have murder
laws why should we even why ken paxton
you're the attorney general of texas why
do you even enforce murder laws stop
stop having the state prosecute murder
laws it's gonna happen anyways bad
people do bad things murder people
murder people all the time so [ __ ]
what who cares just get get greg habit
to make sure to strike down murder laws
what do you need them for if if people
are going to convert murder anyways what
do you need them for you don't need them
you don't need them you don't need stop
signs you don't need stop lights you
don't need [ __ ] speed limits you
don't need any of this [ __ ] people are
going to speed anyways yeah i don't know
i don't know about you but i think uh
deregulating our country would do us a
great deal of good
right
you know i'm sorry when i say that i
can't say that with a straight face
it'll do us a great [ __ ] deal of harm
right well republicans want to
deregulate and many of the reasons that
we have whether it's the economy the
market oh no they don't want to
deregulate gabe that's [ __ ] because
here's what they want to do the same
people that he's about to say that he
wants to give him guns they gotta have
in texas they gotta have more more
[ __ ] license right and more
requirements to receive a license as a
teacher to [ __ ] be a teacher than to
own a gun and
and they regulate what they can and
cannot teach in [ __ ] texas in schools
in the [ __ ] classrooms cause crt is
much more dangerous to your children's
lives than [ __ ]
weapons of war coming in and cutting
them into [ __ ] pieces it's way more
way more dangerous that crt game at crd
at voodoo let's listen cause i've never
understood that argument but we are we
can't harden these schools we can uh
create points of access that are
difficult to get through we can
potentially arm and prepare and train uh
teachers and other administrators to
respond quickly because the reality is
we don't have the resources to to have
law enforcement at every school and so
oh my god this is just [ __ ]
absolutely
who in the [ __ ] texas voted for this
[ __ ] bonehead if you are out there in
texas and you voted for this piece of
[ __ ] you are a god damn scumbag you are
a [ __ ] scumbag you are unpatriotic
you are un-american you are not a
patriot you are a [ __ ] fascist this
guy is talking about turning elementary
schools into [ __ ] prisons my
daughter's school
they had to build gabe they had to
[ __ ] build some kind of special
entrance to make sure that they don't
get murdered
what the [ __ ] are we doing what are we
doing we spend all this money to make
sure they can't get into certain
entrants and the teachers have guns
but make sure they don't learn crt and
all those pencils and erasers and glue
and crayons and all that kind of good
stuff oh to feed them nutrition at
school [ __ ] that we don't need to pay
for that but we don't need to fund that
let's make sure let's make sure that
they're prisons but let's not fund the
actual [ __ ] that they do inside the
school and let's not pay the teachers
either
in
in in some ways i would say those in
prison have more rights and benefits
than those in schools but to that same
point yeah if you're giving teachers
guns
then what's the difference between a
teacher and a guard in a
prison the only difference is that maybe
the people in the prison have more
training
but even then
the prison system the privatized
criticism is so [ __ ] up
and so
twisted
i mean everything that the republican
party supports is [ __ ] up and twisted
that is their [ __ ] ideology at its
core yeah they're fascist
but if you're gonna give teachers
firearms
then what the [ __ ] are they just guards
roaming the halls to make sure that
there's no [ __ ] i just don't get it
he says he says oh we have to have armed
guards teachers as armed guards because
we can't afford law enforcement you
can't even afford to give them [ __ ]
pencils in a racer's dummy
what are you talking about you
[ __ ] don't want to [ __ ] make
sure that kids can get to school can eat
at school look i'm saying i'm saying
kids should start school at the age of
three instead of five i think every
[ __ ] kid i don't care how rich
how poor what color where you're from
if you're a citizen or not you should
get food at that school as much food and
much nutrition that you need year round
365 days a year the parents should be
able to go to the school and feed the
kids in those [ __ ] buildings
and this guy this guy's solution to all
the problems so all the problems in our
country is to make sure entrances are
hard to get into and that teachers have
guns
listen to the nonsense folks that you're
voting for listen to it
is [ __ ] bonehead [ __ ] bonehead oh
mine i i hope he ends up on the list
this week gabe this [ __ ] here
that the whole state of texas lawmakers
are on my [ __ ] personal list right
now the head list yeah the whole the
boneless i call them out in the video
i'm gonna have a i'm gonna have
i was hoping to do the debut uh episode
uh segment of what was that to be about
elon musk and just [ __ ] clown on him
yeah and then yesterday
we have this [ __ ] massacre that
happens with 19 children and two adults
being killed
and i've got a
you know i was just like you know what
[ __ ] it i
i can't i can't do this my only focus
right now is how [ __ ] up and twisted
this situation is and ken paxton is
another example of a republican who
makes the point
for gun regulation
and runs right [ __ ] through it
what he says in this segment
is that the only way to stop this
the only way
to stop these shootings from happening
in the future
at schools which is a wild thing to say
out loud
is to give teachers firearms right now
again we already talked about they
deregulate defund they want to take away
resources but they want to give them
guns that's the solution that's the only
solution they have
but what he says is
we don't have enough uh law enforcement
to patrol the streets or to to guard the
schools
yeah
i gotta stop you we got some breaking
news here
what we have is uh we got a press
conference with uh
with greg abbott and ted cruz i believe
um they're gonna give their thoughts if
we can
um if i can get it going here sorry it's
no it's fine here we go we're at school
some were receiving awards
for perfect attendance
these kids
will never attend
school again
yeah because of you you dumb
[ __ ] and i'm not going to do
anything about it yep not a goddamn
thing
say the least you validity has been
shaken to its core
because of you
families are broken apart because of you
hearts
are forever shattered because of the gop
all texans
are grieving with the people of uvalde
no they're not
and people
are rightfully angry
no you're not about what has happened
yeah wait people are very angry at you
[ __ ]
events like this they tear the fabric of
a community
because of you our job
is to ensure that
the community is not going to be ripped
apart yeah so do your [ __ ] job make
it safe [ __ ] texans must come
together and support the families who
have been affected by this yeah and vote
against your dumbass what they need now
more than ever is someone who will do
something for them
all of our fellow americans
and let me emphasize something that
i know you all know
but the reality is as horrible as
oh
here we go
but here's the butt yeah oh it could
have been worse oh yeah it could have
been 20 kids
is because
law enforcement officials nope
no don't [ __ ] good guy bad guy [ __ ]
here it comes it's incoming good guy bad
guy amazing courage
by running toward gunfire
oh you mean their job of trying
and it is a fact
you mean the swat team came in the
reason the reason why law enforcement
had to run towards the gunfire the
reason why is because greg abbott thinks
it's such a great idea for everyone to
have weapons and and
and his attorney general in his state
wants to make sure that more people have
weapons in that building this is really
[ __ ] stupid this is really this piece
of [ __ ]
but i want to make sure that
everybody knows
all of the law enforcement agencies and
groups that are involved
and were involved in this process
the texas rangers are leading the
investigation
and they are supported by the texas
department of public safety highway
patrol
the texas department of public safety
criminal investigative division
dps aircraft
dps intelligence counter and terrorism
division
dps crime and victim support
there are also thank god for that crime
and victim support guys we're going to
investigate the problem uh we're not
going to look at ourselves here
we're not actually going to do anything
to prevent the mass shootings right
we're just going to investigate them
after the fact and then of course the
valiant local
officials if anything we're going to
give law enforcement more money to
continue to fail right
the people to protect right
because their lives are at risk too
you validity county constables
evaluating mayor the county judge
the valley district attorney's office
local public works and surrounding
police department
and the san antonio police and fire
department also
let me walk you through some of the
facts of what has happened
your fault that's that's the only fact
that right right i made sure that anyone
could own a gun in texas that's what
happened this time understanding
very importantly
that this is an ongoing investigation
and on ongoing investment what i want to
know is what are we what is it i'm going
to investigate
as those investigations progress ongoing
means don't don't investigate
don't investigate the nra don't do that
don't talk about that kind of [ __ ] the
[ __ ] that matters the [ __ ] that would
stop this stuff from happening
she then contacted police
the gunman fled and
as he was fleeing he had an accident
just outside of the elementary school
and he ran into the school
officers with the
consolidated independent school district
they approached the government and
engaged with the gunman well that should
have been it gabe that should have been
it right there good guy we all know this
greg abbott just said it while ago the
only thing that stops a bad guy with a
gun is a good guy with a gun so we
all this nonsense about dead children
and slaughtered children well that's all
[ __ ] because this guy surely stopped
him let's hear the facts
border patrol
consolidated isd officers police
sheriffs and dps officers converged on
that classroom
and a border patrol officer
killed the gunman let's just
listen what he said they had to send
multiple law enforcement agencies to
stop one person with an ar-15 right
so why so this is not a good guy yeah
it's not one good guy with it's not one
good guy with a gun it's this police
agency it's that police it's the border
security right with the gun
that kills a bad guy with a gun like
it's a whole troop of them they need a
whole squad
to kill the bad guy with the gun they
need they need an infantry of men
right to stop this good men good man
good man of course of course of course
yeah come on good guys with guns lots of
good guys with guns will stop a bad guy
bad guy will stop a bad guy with a gun
everyone knows that life threatening
all family members
of
all of these students and faculty
members
should be [ __ ] infuriated with your
dumbass yeah
and they should be speaking out into
microphones denouncing you and anyone
who takes any [ __ ] money from the nra
that's a
and i will give a microphone to any of
those [ __ ] any of those family
members you want to come on the show and
yell and scream you are welcome to come
here and yell and scream at these
[ __ ] you are welcome open
invitation are parents still
striving to make a connection
all parents
are welcome
and urged to
contact he can't he can't even he can't
even put words together when he's
talking about the actual human beings
that are affected by this he's like
actually i don't really care about this
i'm not actually moved by this right so
i'm just going to read off this piece of
paper and the children were um
uh killed oh they had pain whoa what
they had parents he's looking at the
papers like they got parents holy [ __ ]
they got parents oh i thought these kids
were just you know
[ __ ] they were just in the school
they're just they're just warm bodies
they actually had parents this is
surprising this is the first time i'm
reading these facts folks yeah look this
investigation is going great
he used one weapon which was an ar-15
using 223 rounds oh so let's ban it then
oh yeah but that's great that's that's
great that's great greg abbott you know
last you were encouraging this type of
you know yeah he definitely wanted more
of these weapons sold
to this individual i mean jealous of
california
yeah you know what he's probably mad
here that this kid only had one gun he
really wanted he should have had two
[ __ ] [ __ ]
he really should have had more than one
gun because obviously you know we're in
a competition with california he's
really mad at the shooter here that he
didn't have more than one gun to the
point of
he said i'm going to shoot my
grandmother
the second post was
i shot my grandmother
the third post
maybe less than 15 minutes before
arriving at the school was
i'm going to shoot in elementary school
see this is the [ __ ] that they did
last night they act like he just wrecked
happenstance in front of this [ __ ]
school
oh well it was just a happenstance no
no
he was going there to kill those [ __ ]
children to slaughter them to cut them
up in pieces with the [ __ ] gun that
greg abbott is talking about the gun
that greg abbott allowed him to have
right the governor of the state of texas
allowed this person to have this gun he
wanted him to have more
he posted it ah buy more guns that's
what we need
discussion with
community leaders elected officials
and
i asked
the sheriff
and others and opening a question
and
got
the same answer from the sheriff as well
as from the mayor of evality
the question was
what is the problem here
you you're the [ __ ] problem you
are the [ __ ] problem you won't
do anything about the actual problem and
that is the [ __ ] problem like we know
the problem we are aware of what is
going on we are aware of why this is
happening this is not a [ __ ] secret
we've been doing this for [ __ ]
decades now yeah you are the [ __ ]
problem because you won't admit that
it's a problem because you will lose
power if you admit to the actual [ __ ]
problem the nra will disenval you they
will turn their voters on you and you
will not win and now is the time for us
the american people 90 of us that are
sick and tired of [ __ ] boxes like greg
abbott to go [ __ ] vote and turn our
vote on them it's time and now if you
got a few dollars in your pocket and
you're in you're in texas give it to
beto give it to beto that beto can
unseat greg abbott here
for everybody affected
to access mental health
here we go with the [ __ ] mental
health [ __ ] i cannot
be more emphatic than
saying
with great urgency he can't even spit
out the [ __ ] words here with the
mental health like he doesn't even know
where to go with it he doesn't
understand that the parents the teachers
the other students in the school the
[ __ ] community members are gonna need
mental health you know what he's gonna
say to those people that need mental
health [ __ ] health care now because
of because of his policies on guns you
know he's gonna say a big [ __ ] you
that's socialism dummy i'm not gonna
give you socialism why would i do that
and why would we give socialism to crazy
people to give them mental health care
to prevent them from [ __ ] shooting up
schools get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ] you are [ __ ] this is this
is brain dead [ __ ] if you believe
anything that greg abbott says after the
words mental illness anything not a
goddamn word should you believe
everything that republicans say they're
like we care about mental illness we
have a mental illness problem
yeah and then you're not gonna do
anything about that problem
yeah [ __ ] you on that problem we're
gonna be the problem and stand in the
way of doing something about that
problem right because i think we need
mental health care and we need it quick
in this country and we need it for all
these dumb [ __ ] the 10 out
there that aren't for making sure that
people don't get [ __ ] weapons
whenever they want however they want
without a background check that's who
needs mental [ __ ] health care quick
quick and fast and in a hurry let's do
that greg abbott you ain't gonna do [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out of here roll your uh
you roll your on ass down the road it's
enough of this [ __ ]
including the family resource center at
the uvalde county fairplex
schools have crisis teams at the uvalde
civic center
they provide
uh wraparound
services for families who are affected
the texas child when he's saying nra
stuff he doesn't need
he doesn't need the script right in 2019
yeah like he doesn't need the script
when he's talking about nra and guns and
good guys bad guys [ __ ]
but when he's talking about middleweight
memorized right he's oh yeah well they
they
he was in a room with some nra
[ __ ] right before he went out
and did this to make sure he said the
right things that they so that they
would support him and use reelection i
guarantee they had someone that on the
pr team from the nra came in and said
all right listen greg we're going to
brief you on some stuff remember your
answer is a b and c don't mention this
word this word is this word you want to
hit this word this word this word you're
good he's like oh i remember yeah yep i
got it i got it does this mean you're
going to give me money and votes yes it
does if you say these things we will
give you money we will give you votes
don't stray from the script though when
you're talking about the mental illness
thing
you cannot stray from that script greg
you got to keep on that script that is
very important and they had that script
already [ __ ] already lined out i
think nra
had a whole plan whole plan for
because their [ __ ] convention is
going to be this week and they're like
what happened we know there's going to
be a mass shooting in texas before our
convention we definitely need to have a
plan of what our pr strategy is when it
happens
because the people are going to point
that [ __ ] out right you also have to
think that the nra has um
set
responses
and things ready to go on the [ __ ]
ask right as soon as something happens
they'll be like great send this one off
send that one off and send this one off
this person did abc i guarantee their
legal team has gone through a thought
exercise
shut the [ __ ] up you old [ __ ]
drag him out in handcuffs drag him out
and
sick son of a cuffs that would come to a
deal like this to make a political issue
it is a [ __ ] political issue it is a
political issue it's time for the
politics it's time for it folks
i clap for beto aurora to stand up for
these sick sons of [ __ ] get them
better get them
i hope there's better footage than what
we got here
of this event
uh folks if you're just watching the the
news is uh greg greg abbott the the
governor the murderer
of accomplice murderer greg abbott and
the lieutenant governor right before the
lieutenant governor speak better came
into the press conference and started
confronting the governor and the
lieutenant governor good for beto it's
time he came in
and said
look at my [ __ ] face that's right
you're gonna remember this when i come
for your [ __ ] job that's right
look at ted cruz he thinks he's all
tough now
ted cruz standing behind uh governor
greg abbott
there are
there are family members
shut down yeah there are family members
that are pissed off at you i speak
their family members
whose hearts are broken
there's no words that anybody shouting
can come up here yeah there are you god
damn right there are you're fired [ __ ]
you're fired that's the word mark the
battery texan
every american
has a responsibility
where we need to focus not on ourselves
and our agendas we need to focus on the
healing and hope now now now that we can
provide to those who have suffered
unconscionable no that's not damaged to
their lives and loss of life we need to
stop people from [ __ ] tearing
children apart with semi-automatic
rights one moment in time innocent
people in grocery stores put aside
carrying them apart
ourselves
think about the people who were hurt
shut the [ __ ] up
that [ __ ]
i'm sick of this [ __ ] this time
lieutenant governor will speak
[Music]
you little speech to say that um i'm
just about to say shut the [ __ ] up
time to discuss and analyze
what happened yesterday
and figure out
how to pass over and let people have
even more guns
to hopefully
prevent
it from happening
i i really think they're losing the
narrative here and i think better
showed it uh right out in the open um
and he really put him in their place i
hope there's a better footage of that uh
hopefully uh if you can if you are you
searching for footage of beto on i'm
looking on twitter right now um
hopefully there's some better footage
that we can show uh we are we are um 48
minutes past the second hour here on the
tony michaels podcast um but if we can
find some of this better
video where we can launch better roar
arc absolutely [ __ ] destroy
um
here is scott mcfarland let me see if i
can um change the uh
because we were i was going to stay on
for ted cruz but i don't give a [ __ ]
about him [ __ ] you no i don't care at
this point [ __ ] that guy um uh i want to
see what beto said about on this
situation
here is uh
looks the better thread it looks like um
oh did he tweet he's tweeted something
in the last two hours and fourteen hours
here is um
scott mcfarlane um
uh it seems to be a screenshot where
beto is being removed and i think this
is him right down here in the uh bottom
left hand corner of this screen um
where beto has come and uh scott says
pedo aurora confronting
governor greg abbott in the middle of a
press conference in the uvalde shooting
um again we brought it to you here
um i'm glad i went to that breaking news
yeah
for um
to watch beto absolutely eat his lunch
and that's what we need more of folks if
you don't if you don't think that we
need more
more of democrats out there and people
who are who are on the side of
pro-democracy to stand up and yell and
scream and to shout and to fight for the
people who who lives they're gonna save
you are outside your [ __ ] mind we
have to have people who are gonna do
this [ __ ] who are gonna confront these
fascists we have to have it
they're not they're not just coming for
your children's safety in the schools
they're coming for their math they're
coming for your consent for them they
want to marry them they don't want to
give them [ __ ] baby formula based on
the color of their skin and how much
money their parents have they're coming
for you
we have to have someone that will stand
up
uh amy says here it is 17 hours ago but
she says dear texas governor better
o'rourke is the answer since the rest of
the country who's rooting for you
now beto just made a huge splash in
politics just now um it's likely to
change some of the race
oh 100 you even said um earlier beto
o'rourke just interrupted greg abbott's
press conference and said you're doing
nothing thank you beto
um
here's the thing that type of action is
the [ __ ] that we need to do
we can't sit by and wait and say well i
hope these lawmakers finally pass a bill
that's a actually going to be a good for
us and and be the be the
the great thing that we need
[ __ ] that you need to get angry you need
to go vote you need to make sure that
your voice is heard
literally heard going and speaking out
against people like greg abbott and
lieutenant governor and ted cruz in
states like texas and other [ __ ] ass
backward states where they're trying to
take away laws or let you marry kids or
ban books or whatever it is
you need to take this as an opportunity
to stand up and speak out whether it's
behind the keyboard whether it's voting
or whether you physically actually show
up and protest
here is a screenshot that um rachel
biddick offers got caught uh from the
msnbc feed here our msnbc excuse me uh
feed from the press conference where
better auroric approached the stage you
can see the lieutenant governor giving
him the uh
enough of that sir um rachel says thank
you beto uh let's see if we can find uh
more footage in this um
i'm not finding any footage yeah i'm not
finding any footage right now i'm sure
something will come out momentarily i'm
sure somebody
yeah you know screenshotted uh
hopefully there's someone um up close
here that had
um because there's a lot of cameras up
here up front so hopefully someone
caught this and and post this oh you
know what i got one for you
yeah send me a link there and i'll bring
it up here again we're 52 minutes past
the second hour here on the tony
michael's podcast um stick with us here
we're going to try to get you some
footage
of beto o'rourke up close and personal
here we go this is from like the front
run okay okay um
let's see if we can get this going here
oh um paste that's nope that's not what
i want sorry and try i'm trying here
producing on the fly here
um here is uh apparently footage
um looks like just showed up and things
okay here's uh it's a minute long 59
seconds now maybe we can hear betto
let's uh let's listen and see what how
this video is
right now you are doing nothing
[Music]
you said this is not predictable this is
totally predictable
you're on time
[Applause]
this is not the place to do that
it is exactly the place to do it yeah
and
and i applaud better o'rourke and anyone
else who has the [ __ ] nuts to go in
and do this
this will continue to happen somebody
needs to stand up for the children of
this state or they will continue to be
killed just like they were killed in
equality yesterday
i gotta say the [ __ ] goal
of those guys on stage how dare you make
this a political thing you're trying to
politicize these children's deaths shut
the [ __ ] up man what the what is this
whole press conference about right
sitting there and saying well you know
we can't do anything about it we can't
predict it the only thing we can just
investigate it money to law enforcement
and investigate the problem we've
already investigated for decades we know
if you make it easier to get guns guns
will end up killing more people
if we know
that you people are paid by the nra
to not pass laws that would actually
protected citizens
what more investigation do we need
i'm i'm glad he did this if you're in
texas and you haven't gotten your your
payment information on act blue for
better o'rourke at this point uh you're
not doing it correctly um
janie there's a lot of comments rolling
in here about beto but janie says how
the [ __ ] is this man out of line he is
that lineup
well we should be out of line that's
what i'm saying you need to go get out
of line you need to get out of line you
need to get in their [ __ ] faces it's
time it's time to take back our [ __ ]
country it's time to make our kids safe
it's time it's well past time it's been
[ __ ] decades overdue that's right
we're overdue for someone like bet
o'rourke who's running for an office to
go call this what it is it's a bunch of
[ __ ] it's a bunch of talk it's a
bunch of nonsense and he and if you want
to do something in texas vote for
someone who will do something who will
keep your kids safe
it's enough of this [ __ ] [ __ ]
this billy jack [ __ ] from these
republicans be one issue voters only one
issue only one issue matters in this
country right now and that is to get rid
of republicans in power to take back our
democracy they control a small
percentage of the ideology in this
country controls our democracy it's
enough of this [ __ ] it is absolutely
enough of it
the gqp has poisoned the well that is
america they are the root of the evil
and the only way to [ __ ] fix it is to
kill it we gotta pull it out we gotta
get rid of it
to stop this from happening we need to
put leaders and lawmakers in place that
will actually care for its citizens not
just give up empty fodder of thoughts
and prayers and say well the only thing
we can do is uplift the families and the
victims and the communities that were
just tragically uh killed with these
ar-15s and here's the thing guys we
don't know where these ar 15s came from
and we don't know how more of them came
on the streets but is that what i was
supposed to say nra okay cool anyway
like i was saying we don't know how this
is happening and we don't know how to
stop it
that is that is the gqp that is the
republican party
everyone's saying they're gonna pitch in
for beto here if you
again if especially if you're in texas
if you haven't gotten your wallet out
yet to make sure beto aurora gets a few
dollars for what he just did because
everyone democrats are always like oh we
need democrats that'll be tough we need
democrats that'll stand up and spread
the message here's one
here's one he gives not two [ __ ] not
two [ __ ] about what you think about how
he's gonna make sure to protect children
he doesn't care what the lieutenant
governor thinks he doesn't care what the
governor thinks he doesn't even give a
[ __ ] with the old man in the back to
calling him a piece of [ __ ] things he
does not give a [ __ ]
and the only thing that better aurora
cares about at this point is policy that
makes [ __ ] sense that's it that's it
and you want you want democrats that are
going to be tough you want democrats
that are going to be tough on
republicans in the gqp and make sure
this country is not spiraled down into a
fascist state well here's your proof
here's your proof here's what it looks
like folks here's what it looks like
so this moment
this moment right here is the defining
moment
in his campaign i guarantee it this is a
platform issue this is a like you said a
single voter issue
but this is one that is going to [ __ ]
move people that's right you goddamn
right you goddamn right because he's
standing there ty points it out ladies
and gentlemen meet the new governor of
texas beto o'rourke
it's time it's time to use your vote
it's time to use your voice it is time
if you're not registered now you're
doing it wrong register today tomorrow
if you have friends if you have family
if you have church members whoever it is
i don't care what state you're in i
don't care what gerryman or district
you're in i don't care what republican
is always one no matter what get the
[ __ ] off your feet and into the streets
and get that registration mark that
ballot give to those campaigns it's time
now is the time to fight these fascists
with our ballot now is the time and if
you want to see a democrat who is
standing up for our country and standing
up for our children you just saw one
right with bet o'rourke
we're 50 59 minutes in the hour running
out of time today here with the show i'm
gonna play this this one more time uh
with the sound so everyone can hear
better aurora gear
this is on you until you choose to do
something different this will continue
to happen somebody needs to stand up for
the children of this state or they will
continue to be killed just like they
were killed yesterday
[Music]
[Applause]
and what happened to the [ __ ] free
speech huh yeah well say [ __ ] anymore
well you know that elon doesn't own that
venue apparently i uh i saw some people
that were asking about how to uh vote or
how to donate to debato's uh campaign i
just put the link
in the chat so
um
if you want to check it out i'll put it
again
yeah rather you're you're you can just
go to
secure.actblue.com and i'm sure you can
select uh better roark and select uh
candidates that are in your district
canada congressional candidates senate
candidates that are four uh hr eight at
a bare minimum at a bare minimum are for
hr8 right now in the senate uh for bills
to stop bills in these state legislators
it is time for us to take our country
back folks it's time to take away the
power of these [ __ ] fascists that
will do nothing to protect your children
in schools that will do nothing to
protect you in the grocery store hell we
had someone in the comments earlier gabe
talking about how they wear tennis shoes
when they go to the grocery store now in
case they have to [ __ ] run it's
enough
it's enough it's enough it's enough of
this [ __ ]
you are the one who can take this back
you are the one beto beto can make the
policies but only you can vote for him
it's not just texas i mean texas
deserves better texas deserves a
governor like beto that can actually
care for its citizens but all these
other states all these other
representatives whether on a a large
national scale or they're on a local
local municipal level these people need
to be voted out we need to pull the root
of this evil out and put people in who
will actually get things done and care
for the people that they represent and
to do that we need to donate we need to
vote we need to canvas we need to speak
out we need to get our friends we need
to do what we can to make sure that
people like this
actually get in office
it's time now is the time
now is the time if you've been saying
for the last year two years we need
democrats to be tougher we need them to
be tough we need to come at the
republicans well here's what it looks
like right here
right here right now
tomorrow we will cover this we will
cover the fascism that is being that is
being placed upon us that they're trying
to have a fascist state trying to
silence our [ __ ] voices
when it comes to guns when it comes to
children's school when it comes to math
when it comes when it comes to your
consent of your child
when it comes to your uterus when it
comes to your decisions with you and
your doctor
when it comes to the supreme court
we will not stop here at the tony
michaels podcast every single weekday
monday through friday just like betto
i'm not gonna stop i don't give a [ __ ]
don't give two [ __ ] i'm gonna come
after these son of a [ __ ] one way or
the other
and i hope you will join us every single
weekday monday through friday two hours
live youtube twitter twitch don't forget
to subscribe to the youtube channel also
we simulcast to the facebook page of
midas touch the link is at the top of
the page for the for the youtube channel
please subscribe please follow please
watch we love the new listeners we love
the engagement here uh today was a very
very very
scorched earth day and tomorrow is
likely to be two i will probably still
be pissed tomorrow folks oh yeah or tune
in tune in tomorrow live
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube twitter twitch or the mind touch
facebook page until tomorrow surfs up
[ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking